for the flip of the page the musk of old
paper the newsprint on our fingers this
is why we love comics from the morning
commute to late nights by flashlight and
sneaking them in class this is why we
love comics because the grandpa they're
the funnies - dad they're comic books to
us they're graphic novels this is why we
love comics for Sunday mornings and new
comics day for your pull list and your
RSS feed for spinner racks and long
boxes for bags boards and an extra room
to store them all this is why we love
comics for superheroes anti-heroes and
everyday heroes for the mainstream
independent and underground because
we're first in line when Hollywood gets
them right and first on line when they
get them wrong this is why we love
comics
for late-night inking for xeroxing and
stapling and calling ourselves
publishers for standing for Jack and
Alan and Neil for Maggie and Coleen and
Jerry and Mike this is why we love
comics for the aisles of Comic Con or a
local hotel ballroom for spending months
making a costume will wear for only one
day this is why we love comics because
Charlie Brown taught us how to read
Batman taught us how to draw and
Superman taught us how to be brave this
is why we love comics
because with only four colors some
pictures and words they can make us
laugh make us think transport us to
other worlds and make us feel closer to
home for millions of reasons and the
flip of that next page this is why we
love comics